if you wanted to create a new personal
reality a new life you'd have to change
your personality which means you'd have
to start thinking about what you've been
thinking about and change it you'd have
to become aware of your unconscious
habits and behaviors and even what you
say and modify them and then you'd have
to look at those emotions that keep you
anchored to the past and decide if those
emotions belong in your future so most
people try to create a new personal
reality as the same personality and it
doesn't work we literally have to become
someone else in other words thoughts are
the language of the brain and feelings
are the language of the body and how you
think and how you feel creates a state
of being so most people have experiences
in their life that brand them
emotionally they feel fear they feel
anger they feel bitterness they feel
frustration they feel insecurity and
those emotions then become part of their
identity so once they think certain
thoughts that turn on certain circuits
in their brain the moment they feel
insecure they think more insecure
thoughts which makes more chemicals for
them to feel insecure and there
repetition of that cycle over time
conditions the body to subconsciously
become the mind of insecurity so then
the person says I am insecure and
whenever you say I am anything you're
commanding your mind and body towards a
destiny hey it's Evan Carmichael and I
make these videos because in my first
business I was making 300 bucks a month
I quit on my business partner and the
thing that saved me was studying the
stories of super successful
entrepreneurs so I hope that this story
today helps give you the motivation you
need because I still needed to myself so
today let's learn how you can manifest
10 times faster enjoy
[Music]
most peoples
biology is for the most part their past
and so if you're not being defined by
the vision of the future some new
possibility in your life you're only
left with the old circuitry in your
brain and the old emotions of the past
so the question then is
can you believe in a future
that you can't see or experience with
your senses yet
but you've thought about enough times in
your mind
that your brain is literally changed to
look like the experience has already
occurred now the latest research in
Neuroscience says you can change your
brain just by thinking
so then as you begin to think about a
new possibility and your brain begins to
fire in new sequences and new patterns
and new combinations and you begin to
plan your behaviors and you begin to
review in your mind mentally rehearse
who you're going to be in your life the
mere action of mental rehearsal begins
to install the neurological circuits in
your brain now your brain is no longer a
record of the past
now it's in fact a map to the Future
and if you were then to begin to
emotionally embrace your future before
it's made manifest in other words
you're not waiting for your healing to
feel wholeness you're not waiting for
your new relationship to feel love
you're not waiting for the mystical
moment to feel awe you're not waiting
for your success to feel empowered
that's the old model of reality of cause
and effect in other words the
materialist
the person who's waiting for their
wealth to come to feel abundance
they're living by that model of cause
and effect but the quantum model is
about causing an effect which means you
begin to experience your own worthiness
and your abundance before it occurs you
have to feel wholeness in order for your
healing to occur
we have to feel love for ourselves and
love for life in order for us to have
love in our life
and so then to instruct people how to
teach their body emotionally how that
future could feel like before it's made
manifest
if they do it properly their body is the
unconscious mind begins to believe it's
living in that future reality in the
present moment and they're beginning to
Signal new genes in new ways that begins
to change their body to look like the
event has already occurred rule number
two is believe with Gabby Bernstein he
will manifest what we believe
there's a big butt here
we often have an idea of what we want to
bring into our life have a vision of who
we want to be have a desire
but the biggest thing that's blocking us
from stepping into that truth is the
belief
that's literally backstage just now with
somebody and she was like I really just
can't wait to be you know doing more of
what you're doing and I and I looked at
her and I was like you will and then I
stopped myself and I said no no you are
you are
doesn't matter like the audience size it
doesn't matter the reach it's like
you're just doing it and so when we get
that and we believe that then it just
multiplies the universe conspires
and I know I'm not unfamiliar with
lacking belief in any way shape or form
17 years ago would never in a million
years have believed that I would be here
right here right now with all of you
that I would have had the career I've
had the life that I've had the husband I
have the child I have nope never would
have believed it
and there's one moment in particular I
can think my way back to I'm I'm 24
years old and I'm sitting in my white
beat up Toyota Corolla
and I'm adhering to alternate side of
the street parking regulations in New
York City if anybody knows New York you
have to sit on the side of the road
until the street cleaners come behind
you very sexy so I'm sitting there and
I'm in my wife beat up Toyota Corolla
and I'm just shielding my eyes from the
Sun and I'm drinking this Gatorade
and I'm coming down from the night
before
I have not slept I was just at an
after-hours party about 30 minutes prior
no business being behind the wheel
and I'm just in the card I'm pressing
play
and rewind on my cassette tape
play
rewind
play
rewind
play Rewind
over and over I'm listening to the voice
of this psychic medium who I had had a
reading with five months earlier
and I hear the psychic's voice say to me
you're struggling with drugs and alcohol
it's not that bad I respond quivering
literally
and she goes on to say my dear you have
two choices in this lifetime
you can choose to stay on this path and
really suffer really struggle with
addiction
or
you can choose to get clean and sober
and make a major impact on the world
play Rewind
play Rewind
you can choose to get sober and make a
major impact on the world play and
Rewind you can choose to get sober and
make a major impact on the world
and I feel her words
and I want that truth
but I don't believe it
I don't have any proof of how that would
be possible
I don't believe I'm worthy of that
I'm afraid to even contemplate what it
would take to get there
I just kept pressing play Rewind
then I noticed the street cleaners
coming behind me and so I have to move
the car across the street I park the car
I look outside my window and I see all
these people with their shoulder bags
and their coffees and their dogs and
they're all walking somewhere they're
going to work they're doing something
special in the world and I'm going
nowhere I'm going nowhere
and I sit in that car and I just chug
that final Gatorade I throw the Gatorade
bottle on the car I step out of the car
I walk across the street to my studio
apartment that's on the ground floor
with the garbage cans outside the window
I get into the shower the shower is kind
of like crusty and moldy and I just let
the water just flush down my face and
I'm seeing this mascara just dripping
down my eyes in the mirror
at which point I take some kind of
Downer just to fall asleep and I get in
my bed with that Downer waiting for it
to set in and I start to feverishly
journal in my journal over and over and
over again get sober and you can make a
major impact on the world get sober and
you can make a major impact on the world
just just over and over and over and I
hear the clanking noises of the garbage
cans outside my window and just gets
softer and softer and softer and the
pill starts to set in the anxiety will
subside
until I wake up later
I think my way back
to that girl 24 year old girl
with a stack of self-help books next to
her bed her journal in her hand
and I can think about how
her belief
and her faith
we're stronger than her fear
and in that experience of knowing that
she could transcend that addiction that
she could transcend the traumas of her
past
and step into the light of who she was
here to be rule number three is
visualize the bridge with Mel Robbins
mantras don't work if you're picking a
mantra you don't believe and if you're
picking a mantra that is the opposite of
the way you treat yourself and the
actions you take so that's number one
number two manifesting everybody has
been sold a bill of goods about
manifesting
if you make a vision board with your uh
house on the ocean or you at the stock
exchange ringing the bell and that's all
that you have on it
science says that that vision board will
become a source of profound
discouragement
because over time as you sit there and
stare at your dream house or you ringing
the bell at NASDAQ and nothing in your
life changes
you start to feel further and further
and further away from what you want
which makes you feel further and further
discouraged which means you're less and
less motivated to even begin working on
it like the hardest part for everybody
is to start and the reason why is not
only the patterns of procrastination and
anxiety and stuff that you get trapped
in but it's also because your goals feel
so far away that you don't believe that
just starting is going to even chip away
at it and so number one because it
sounds like I just contradicted myself
yes you need to have something like a
beach house or the NASDAQ Bell or the
business you're starting or the love
affair of your life or the family you've
always envisioned or the health that
you've always dreamed about absolutely
swing for the fences what do you want it
to look like 10 years from now
but when it comes to manifesting based
on science I want you to think as
manifesting as a bridge
manifesting is a bridge that's made of
bricks between you
and the thing that you dream about
and what you do when you manifest is you
don't manifest where the bridge is going
you manifest the bricks
so a great example is a marathon so
let's say that you've never run a day in
your life but your bucket list is to
complete the London Marathon
yes you can put on your vision board
a photograph of a runner crossing the
London Marathon you can even put the
dream that you have in terms of the the
number that you want the time to be okay
but you better put a runner in the rain
up there
you better put an alarm clock that says
4 30 in the morning because that's what
time you're going to have to get up in
order to get your training runs in you
better put a runner that's gripping
their leg like this when they get a
muscle cramp you better put up uh you
know a vision of you at Mile 13 and your
earbuds run out and you still got two
more miles to go
visualization is the bricks and so what
I want you to do when you visualize is
instead of visualizing ah the marathon I
did it I was amazing and then you open
up you're like okay and I still have not
even bought a pair of sneakers
that's not happening but that was a fun
little exercise no what you do is you
literally visualize walk into the store
and get sneakers
call your friend who runs and ask for
advice
oh my God that's me on my first training
run I've only gone 30 seconds and I'm
out of breath oh there I am running
three miles in the rain and I feel proud
of myself because I've actually gone out
in the rain oh there I am saying uh no
to my friends I can't go out tonight
because I didn't get my running but I'm
gonna go on my big run alone that like
you visualize the annoying irritating
amazing things also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number four is be in a state of
certainty with Tony Robbins think about
what's the Holy Grail between somebody
taking action or not it's one word
certainty
when somebody is absolutely certain they
you know the common word is believe
right but you know you can believe at a
general level or you can believe with
certain when you're absolutely certain
that if I do this it's going to get that
result and that result's going to change
my life you'll do it
when you think it absolutely is not
going to work you're never going to do
it the middle no man's land of maybe
it'll work maybe it won't that's the
piece that kills people right so if it's
a must for you you got to make it work
right in our case right it's an example
it's not a must for you and you're not
sure you don't know what to do so I
years ago I'd look around and say okay
how do people get themselves to follow
through that haven't been following
through what's the difference and I
started interviewing hundreds of people
literally eventually thousands because I
had thousands of my events so I'd ask
the group to give me the feedback they
came up with this model it's like the
Holy Grail of belief or the Holy Grail
of momentums like the difference between
what makes the rich get richer and the
poor get poorer right and the difference
we all know is mindset but like how's
that built so this is the idea I create
a stupid little little boxes and I'll
scribble it here for it
you think about the first thing that
determines whether you can do something
or not and I put that in this first box
at the top here on the left side it's
potential like what's the potential of a
human being like when you guys started
you proved something no one had done in
history you ran the four minute mile
right for golly knows how many centuries
they're trying to run a four minute mile
Roger Bannister does it how did he do it
do you remember
you did it in this industry right you
made a million bucks in a day no one had
ever done that in history right after
you did it a bunch of other guys are
doing it because it became possible
Roger Bannister didn't just go
physically practice he made a shift in
his head he practiced in his head
because he could never achieve it
physically so he had a change in his
head first so the result became certain
enough he believed it and then his body
got him through after Roger Bannister in
that four minute mile
within two years 37 people ran a four
minute mile that's amazing no one in
history never done it here's how it
works the potential for anybody getting
your product is extraordinary they can
do what you've done as much more or less
they can do whatever they want to do the
potential is there the Market's proven
that
whether or not they tapping that
potential has a lot to do with what
action they take which is a question you
came to me with right like you know God
they almost potential but they're not
taking action and we all know that the
action the dague is going to determine
the results they get
that's pretty obvious
so most people have a belief about what
their real potential is no matter what
you tell them
and that affects how much action they
take and of course that affects the
result and then ironically that result
reinforces their belief
and then that belief affects it so I'll
give an example
let's say a person has unlimited
potential we all agree but they take
little action little results why because
they have to start with a problem with
their belief they don't believe it's
really going to happen for me maybe for
Frank Kearns because it's got the cool
hair and stuff or maybe it's for you
because you're so driven but it's not Me
Maybe Tony Robbins because he's afraid
got these big teeth whatever their
thought process is right they got this
thing right but what happens is if you
believe that there's very little
potential how much action you're going
to take
nothing stop it Little and when you take
little potential with a little action
what kind of results do you get
lousy little results and when you get
little results what does that do to your
belief it goes C I told you this was a
waste of time Soldier this wouldn't work
and then what happens you tap even less
potential you take even less action you
get even worse results and your belief
gets even weaker and this sucker feeds
on itself until you are in the downward
spiral poisonous it's poisonous and it's
self-fulfilling now what if something
could happen that could come along and
fill you with a sense of absolute
certainty not like I believe but I mean
well you know in you guys's case mine as
well we knew because we had to right
because we burned the boats there was no
other option we had to find the way we
had we weren't going to live that way we
all did it in different ways and for
different reasons but in essence that
was it
get yourself in a state of certainty
that this is going to work I'm going to
find a way and if this doesn't work I
will make the way then you tap a lot
more potential and when you're certain
in your potential you take Massive
Action when you take Massive Action you
really believe in something you get
great results when you get great results
your brain goes see I told you I was a
stud
I told you this thing would work out now
you're even stronger you tap more
potential take greater action greater
results that's how you win from 300
bucks in a week to 2500 five days to a
hundred thousand in a month to a million
bucks in a day same thing with you and
we get momentums why the rich get richer
and the poor get poorer rule number five
is aligned with spiritual reality with
Bruce Lipton something you look at in
spontaneous Evolution too is how science
and spirituality are coming together
they used to be very separate absolutely
the the scientific World which is very
factual driven and that's that and you
couldn't change it and spirituality was
trying to open up things but they really
are meeting now aren't they yeah it was
interesting because um the spiritual
world of religion was talking about the
invisible moving forces that shape the
physical reality and we call them spirit
and then science uh only came into
existence because it made a detaunt with
the church in the very early days of
science it said look we won't tread on
your invisible spiritual domain we will
just study the physical world and when
Newton was able to predict the movements
of the planet by just looking at the
physical features then scientists got
the idea as well if you can understand
how the universe operates by just
studying the material where we don't
need that invisible stuff but in 1925
Newtonian physics was incorporated
subsumed by a bigger physics called
quantum physics and quantum physics
emphasizes the universe is made out of
energy it's not made out of matter and
then I say well what does the quantum
physicist call this energy that the
universe is made out of I say well they
call it the field I said what's the
definition of the field I love this
invisible moving forces that influence
the physical world I go my goodness
that's the same definition as spiritual
it's used for spirit I go yes quantum
physics emphasizing the invisible uh
field as primary to the physical world
is essentially reiterating the statement
of the spiritual people who talked about
the invisible forces shaping our
physical existence and so by definition
science the new science of quantum
physics is bringing us back into
alignment with the spiritual reality
hopefully uh the the dogmatic beliefs of
the church which had talked about these
wonderful terms but didn't allow us to
live there and science which is still
stuck in its material plane will both
divest themselves of their dogma and
allow us to come together and recognize
that we're all part of that invisible
field that that we don't even live in
our own bodies if you understand the
nature of how the cell works so we are
part of the field being downloaded into
our body that we're all by definition
the field or we're all spiritual same
definition and and if we recognize this
the unity of it and that you cannot be
taken out of the field and you cannot be
in a sense punished by the field you are
the field then maybe the beliefs those
very restrictive beliefs from both
science and from the dogmatic religion
will disappear but because the people
owning their own spirituality owning
their own responsibility and not saying
oh which spirits that did this or things
other factors that we are the creators
will generate a new world because what I
firmly believe is very simple go out and
talk to the average person anywhere in
the world and say if you could create a
world what would you like well I'd like
a world where there's peace and Harmony
and I like some food and a job and I go
isn't it amazing how everywhere you go
in the world virtually entire population
has the same belief I go then how come
we don't have an answer is because the
leadership isn't exercising that belief
so I trust the people
to take over the leadership of this
world and that the structure that is is
actually in a state of collapse when it
collapses this will be our opportunity
to evolve from the very destructive
darwinian perception of a world
into a more holistic holism that says
we're all part of the same system we're
all cells in the same body and when we
work together we will create Magic on
this earth like nothing has ever been
seen before so I'm very optimistic about
that and rule number six the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is
shift your thoughts with Lewis house the
first thing you want to think about is
switching from negativity to positivity
so many people get caught up in focusing
on what they don't want to happen in
their future and I want to talk about
this a little bit towards the end of
this video on how to focus on some of
the negative things that could happen
but really focusing on the positive for
the main part of your life we'll talk
about that towards the end because this
is an important distinction but they
start living almost in constant fear of
what could go wrong and what won't work
out and when we come from this place of
well I don't know if I put myself out
there you know it's not going to work
out and then I'm going to get made fun
of and then people I'm going to be
embarrassed and I'm going to be stressed
and no one's going to love me and then
we go in this rabbit hole and this kind
of cycle of fear and anxiety and that is
not how you attract good things in your
life you can't
start from your way of being of
negativity and fear and expect to
attract beautiful things in your life
so we we need to eliminate the negative
self-talk and an environment that's easy
to get stuck in sometimes can be the
negative self-talk and there's so much
negativity in the world and if you don't
actively work to shift your focus to
shift your thoughts and your mind that
negativity will consume you
you will never find working a pleasure
if you hate your job or you can't stand
your boss what a terrible affirmation
that is it will be impossible for you to
ever attract a great job with that
belief system if you want to enjoy your
time at work then you must change your
thinking I'm a great believer in
blessing with love every person place
and thing at the workplace begin with
your current job affirm that this job is
merely a stepping stone to far greater
positions
you are in your current job because of
the things you believed in the past you
drew it to you by your thinking perhaps
you learned your attitude towards work
from your parents no matter you can
change your thinking now
so bless with love your boss your
co-workers the location the building the
stairs or elevators the rooms the
furniture and each and every customer
this creates a loving mental atmosphere
within you and the whole office will
respond to it
I have never understood the reasoning
behind putting down or berating others
at work if you are an owner a manager or
supervisor how can you possibly expect
to get the best work from others if they
are frightened or resentful we all want
to be appreciated acknowledged and
encouraged
if you support your employees and give
them respect then they will give you the
best work they can
now please don't believe that it is hard
to get a job that may be true for many
but it does not have to be true for you
you only need one job and your
Consciousness will open the pathway for
you
don't have faith in fear when you hear
of negative Trends in business or in the
economy immediately affirm that may be
true for some but it is not true for me
I always Prosper no matter where I am or
what is going on
people often ask me for the affirmations
to make the relationships at work be
smoother in fact for many people this is
a really big issue in their lives I am
deeply aware that whatever I give out
comes back to me multiplied and this is
true everywhere including at work
in the workplace it is important to know
that every employee and employer has
been attracted by the action of love for
it's his and her divine right place here
and now at this point in time and space
Divine Harmony permeates us all and we
can all flow together in the workplace
in a most productive and joyous way
there aren't any problems that don't
have Solutions there aren't any
questions without answers
choose to go beyond the problem to seek
the Divine Right action solution to any
Discord that may seem to appear
be willing to learn from any Discord or
confusion as it comes up it's important
to release all blame and turn within to
seek the truth
and be willing to release whatever
pattern may be in your Consciousness
that has contributed to the situation
know that you are successful in all that
you do you're inspired and productive
you serve others willingly and gladly
Divine Harmony Reigns Supreme within and
around you and within and around each
and every person in your workplace
when you know and declare that it's
possible to successfully operate in the
workplace according to Divine principles
then Divine love brings to you those who
can be helped by that which you so
lovingly do
now if you like your job but feel you're
not getting paid enough then bless your
current salary with love expressing
gratitude for what you do have enables
it to grow
and absolutely no more bitching about
the job or co-workers your Consciousness
puts you where you are now your changing
Consciousness can lift you to a better
position you can do it
during your work day there are a number
of things you can do to release tension
here are a few ideas
one before you go to work every day do
this simple exercise just sit
comfortably and concentrate on your
breath
whenever you notice thoughts coming in
gently bring your awareness back to your
breath
give yourself at least 10 or 15 minutes
to dwell in the silence each day there
is nothing difficult or tricky to this
and it's worth taking the time
two write or type this affirmation and
put it where you can see it at work my
job is a peaceful Haven I bless my job
with love I put love in every corner and
my job lovingly responds with warmth and
comfort I am at peace
when you start to think about your boss
say this affirmation to yourself
I only give out that which I wish to
receive my love and acceptance of others
is mirrored to me in every way
refuse to be limited in any way by human
mind thinking
your life can be filled with love and
joy because your work is a Divine idea
remember to say to yourself every day
before going to work no matter where I
am there is only infinite good Infinite
Wisdom infinite Harmony and love I think
one of my first things in failure
is don't take it more personally than it
actually is and I'll give an example of
that when I was applying to 40 companies
that all rejected me before an interview
yeah all I was getting was an automated
response saying your application will
not go any further
can't take that personally because they
didn't meet me in person they didn't
have a interaction with me they just saw
my name they saw I'd been a monk for
three years that resume is useless I
mean what's your transferable skills
like sitting in silence yeah surprising
because no one wants to hire a monk and
so they rejected you but that's not
personal because they didn't meet me in
person but what if they had me right so
that's the first thing the first step is
don't take all fear failure I'll give an
example me and you we reach out to
countless guests to be on our podcast we
say no all the time we're saying all the
time but if I don't hear a no from the
guest directly that's not a no like
someone's team can say no someone's
assistant can say no someone's PR team
can say no but until they say no
personally it's not a no okay but when
they do say no then that's enough yeah
so then let's move how do you deal with
that type of failure yes so if I deal
with a failure where someone meets me in
person and gets to know Jay you're
horrible you suck like I don't want to
deal with a monk ever in my life yeah I
would never go on your show I'm never
listening to you never yeah that how do
you deal with that type of so I've had
you say this I've said it a couple of
times and I'm sure it's been repeated a
bunch of times around how I genuinely
believe failure has feedback feedback
and and so for me it's like failure has
the ability to actually tell you what
you need to improve now not to improve
to get their attention
improving to get the actions that you
want to take yeah the results you want
the results you want and don't make that
result about the person who said no
don't try use failure as a way to prove
someone else wrong because what happens
when we prove others wrong when you
prove others wrong you end up trying to
get validation and approval for them and
now if they're not impressed when you're
right you lose again so you end up
losing twice and you spend all this time
and energy years maybe to prove
something wrong I've been there many
times and then you're like I felt good
for a moment yeah and then I feel empty
again totally and and so that's the
thing about failure in the second half
is you have to see failure as an
improvement if if I'm completely honest
everyone who rejected me in my life up
until now
has made me more hungry taught me so
much more about myself and made me up my
game yeah and I think if failure doesn't
make you up your game it's the same as
losing in a sport
right when you fail and you've lost
games and you've won games you know on
the big stages you didn't have the
skills you didn't have the teamwork you
guys weren't hungry enough you were
communicating enough there's something
you were missing yeah so you go review
the game film you check the stats you
see what could have done better and you
try to improve that for the next game
yeah I think a lot of people can do that
in life but we're so afraid to like go
on the next game of life like I got
rejected once and it hurts so bad yeah
how do people learn to overcome that
pain of rejection yeah to keep going
yeah you know in sports luckily there's
a season which like you might have 30
basketball games after you lose the
first two you don't say uh I'm just
gonna give up the rest of the season
yeah you keep playing yes but in life a
lot of people stop playing yeah why yeah
I think that's great mental training too
I think Sports is great mental training
because you have to show up to the next
game even if you lost and you don't feel
bad exactly that you don't feel good
sorry and and one of the things before I
dive into that question one of the
things that you reminded me of was that
the Lost dance documentary so there's
that season that Michael Jordan everyone
is agreement in an agreement that he is
one of the best players to be playing
and they keep losing they need to make
the fight they didn't make the finals
they lost and then they realized they
need to get the team and they need to
find their I think they're bringing
Dennis Rodman and then they start
bringing in all these other players that
strengthen whereas if they would have
just said oh we got the best player in
the world we just keep doing this
I'm not sure what they would have got
there right but the coach Phil Jackson
and the team they had to adapt and so
you're saying why do we feel that pain
in rejection and how do we deal with
that
I think we feel that pain because we
look at a failure right we look at it as
a complete definition of us right we're
looking at as as uh there's that famous
statement of like you know failure is an
event not a person right and I don't
know who said it but it's one of those
statements that that really clicks like
failure is uh an event not a person
whereas we start thinking we are the
failure like we say I am a failure
what is fear is fear something that you
should fear
no
I want you to imagine as you're driving
down the street in your car
and a light pops up on the dashboard a
light pops up
um
have you ever taken a hammer and hit the
light because you don't like the light
of course not that would be silly right
what if the light on the dashboard was
just a signal maybe you're low on tire
air pressure maybe you're missing air or
water in your windshield wiper maybe the
back trunk door is open isn't the signal
in your car
just for you to be aware that maybe
something is wrong or something needs
attention
is it possible that if we stop thinking
of fear as the enemy fear is one of your
biggest friends why well when you
understand how did this organism
okay develop and how does it keep us
alive
it pays attention to things okay in your
external World triggers from your
external word that could cause your
death or destruction it causes you to do
what when there is a Potential Threat
predator or threat at the door it lights
up the fear signals since cortisol
epinephrine or norepinephrine into your
bloodstream so you either know how to
fight it you run away or you freeze
hoping that the Predator will go away so
when your brain every brain
gets this signal that there is a threat
at the door
it sends a signal
in the form of a neurochemical that you
feel
now if somebody
feels this threat in their body but they
don't know how to manage the emotion we
call fear let's say there's a fear that
you have a failure and what it might
mean to your family what's what about a
fear of losing money and not having
enough to pay the rent the mortgage or
for retirement what if there's a fear of
trying something and then it not working
out and you're embarrassed or ashamed or
ridiculed or rejected or judged oh my
God if you judge me then you're going to
reinforce my low self-esteem of myself
and then always then who am I
you understand what's happening in the
circuits I'm just describing
so when our brain has this Fierce
circuit activated do you think the fear
circuit causes you to go oh hey let's
take action anyway or do you think it
goes high alert high alert high alert be
aware what's going on what if you fail
what if you succeed what if succeed and
fail whenever that circuit is triggered
motivational circuit shuts down whenever
that circuit is activated your thinking
circuit shuts down all the blood flow
goes into a part of your brain to help
you do what possibly run away protect
yourself it's a protection mechanism but
here is what I want you to remember this
automatic trigger and circuit has been
evolving for millions of years but your
specific experiences since you were born
in the modeling experiential and the
um and the imprinting years caused you
to have
beliefs about things some Empower you
some disempower let me give you an
example
okay let me give you an example when I
say the word
or let me give you a different uh the
same example with just a little
different story
if I say to you that I'd like to take a
big snake about five feet long and let
it Slither across your arm and around
your neck and it's a python how many of
you go oh wow that would be great
versus how many of you are going oh my
God let me run away get get it off of me
just just think of a snake slithering on
you and curling itself around your neck
how many of you are like run versus oh
my God that would be great to take a
picture of me with it so I put on social
media
so is it really the snake that is the
threat or is it your Concept in your
brain the meaning that you have
associated with a snake that is
activating for some of you the reward
center and for others the fear Center
same stake stained stimuli there isn't
even a snake here I just add you think
about it
right and it triggered that fear circuit
for some reward circuit for others so
it's never about the thing so when we
have fear of being embarrassed ashamed
ridiculed judged uh fear of
disappointing ourselves fear of failing
fear of succeeding there's 50 different
types of fears we automatically trigger
the circuit that does what stops our
action taking consistent action is the
cure-all whatever problem you have
whatever issue you're facing whatever
big life you want to create for yourself
the way to get there is not some giant
short burst of effort it's the daily
consistent grinding action that will
help you accomplish your goals people
look at my channel and
a lot of new people have joined over the
past number of years hey welcome board
great to have you welcome to believe
Nation it's a positive happy place it's
great to have you here it's an honor to
be a part of your daily routine
if you go and look at my my channel my
main channel in the history it took so
many years guys so many years of just
making content and not seeing any
results
I took I forget what the number is it
took five years to get to 9 000
something subscribers and another five
years to get almost two million
subscribers now we're sitting over three
million subscribers Etc
I haven't missed
an upload every single day
for I don't know
eight years
something crazy like that
every day
I've made videos through
travel I've made videos through elect
electricity electricity outages I made
videos through breaking my neck I made
videos through my tour I made videos
through vacation I made videos I made
videos I made videos I made videos I
made videos I made videos and you can
plan you can prepare you can get ahead
you can you can batch them
but I don't think your goals count until
they're hard
it's when it gets hard when when you get
tested that's when you have to show
yourself What You're Made Of
even little things like
I remember filming at my dance studio in
Toronto
and I had my camera guy and my assistant
and we're filming and the electricity
goes out
and then there's a fire alarm
they go I guess we can't film like the
first thing that that my camera guy says
is okay well I guess we can't film I
can't film with this like electricity
outage and then
fire alarm
fire alarm
you can't film with that it's like I'm
I'm filming today
so I took my phone it was freezing
outside I took my phone went outside and
just started filming
because videos have to go up
they have to go up
I've I've made videos with my broken
neck
I broke my neck in two spots had a
concussion
and I
next week I'm making videos
they weren't as long they weren't as
good
I'm wearing a neck brace if you look at
the old videos I'm wearing this giant
neck brace I got this giant scab here on
my forehead because I smashed my head
against the wall
when I fainted and that's how it led to
the concussion broken neck I'm still
making videos
not making videos is not an option
and so if you look at someone like me
who
is introverted is shy who doesn't like
the camera who always thought that
people who are famous had a big ego who
I still don't like being on stage I
still get nervous every single time
but I still have a message
and I still want to serve how does
somebody like that
have this kind of Channel well because
of every single day making videos you've
done over 10 000 videos I've done over
10 000 videos that's crazy
not all of them are public
but even just on the main Channel let
alone this channel on the top 10 channel
the other channel 10 000 Plus videos
over 12 years
why
how
it's just a consistent action
I think most people lose because
we overestimate what we can do
in a really
short period of time and underestimate
what we can do in a long period of time
you think by putting in three weeks of
hard work you're gonna crush it
but really if you just stayed on it like
guys you've had ideas you have enough
you've you have had an idea that you've
loved that you gave up on too soon that
if you just kept doing it this is an
idea that you had maybe three years ago
that if you just found the way to keep
doing it even part-time even on the side
even on the weekends if you just kept at
it you'd be in a different place right
now
something would have happened something
would have paid off
but we're too frustrated to get
something to happen right now and I get
it I'm there too I'm I'm impatient I
want immediate results I want things to
happen I'm putting my best I want this
video right now to be the best one I've
ever done and I put my effort to try to
make that happen and I fully recognize
at the same time that
it's a long game
that you have to keep going
and that it's your purpose you can't
give up on it
most people just quit too soon
you just quit too soon
and that's you quitting on your dream
and it was your dream and you want it to
happen it's a daily consistent Act
action to make it happen
so how do you do it let me give you some
tactics so that you can not just get
motivated from a message but actually
apply it to your life number one you
have to create a calendar
these videos happen because you're in my
calendar
I'm filming this on a Tuesday Tuesday is
my YouTube day I always film on Tuesday
I block it off in my calendar
I just came back from vacation and on
the Tuesday of my week I was still
making videos people say well we still
work on vacation first off it's not work
like I like this this is fun for me this
isn't this isn't oh I have to go make
videos if that was my mindset I would
I'd be out I wouldn't do it anymore
but also if you're on vacation you're
making videos or you're doing a little
bit of work
to spend three hours
of a 24-hour day
doing something
is totally achievable somebody one of
the people that I invested into
yesterday's like how do I take a
vacation on my business
like how do I my wife wants to know how
do I go on vacation and run this
business like you can still you can
either plan ahead and get ahead with all
your clients or you can still do some
work
do you not have personal time are you
going to be around your wife 24 hours a
day does your wife not want to go to the
spa or spend some time on the beach it's
not about the three hours that you spend
working it's about
the other hours at 21 hours you get to
sleep but whatever all the other hours
that you have the day it's about
intentional time most of most people's
life is not intentional most of your
vacation time is not intentional either
if you were to spend 21 hours a day with
your wife
intentionally creating an amazing
relationship
then the three hours a day you're going
to spend working
as easy as nothing
of course you could take time off
but you have to put in your calendar
you have to create a calendar that makes
sense for you
schedule in when you're actually going
to make your dreams happen because
otherwise it's a dream I could say I
want to make YouTube videos but if it
was never my calendar guess what it
would never happen and this applies for
life too every uh every afternoon
at 2 30 I spend time with Nina with my
wife
we spend time in the morning I take an
intentional break at 2 30 we go to the
park we take we take the dogs with us
we we stay inside and just be together
if it's raining like we'll spend time
every day every weekday at 2 30 because
I want I wanted to spend more time with
Nina during the week weekends we're
basically all in on on the relationship
but the weekdays can be crazy you know
so we spend time in the morning we spend
time in the evening and I wanted to
spend
2 30. it's 25 minutes together but
intentional 25 minutes that intentional
25 minutes is worth more than three
hours of just sitting in front of a TV
that's not time together
you have a lot more time than you think
you're just not being intentional that's
the problem if you feel like you got to
the end of the week and you were so busy
but you got nothing done
and everything's falling apart you're
just not intentional with your time
so you schedule it in whatever you want
in a life whatever your dream life looks
like whatever your goals Ambitions
motivations are put in your calendar
two
be the person who follows through on
their calendar
stop letting yourself off the hook
for not following through on your
calendar
I'm a little tired today because we just
came back from our trip I'm a little jet
lagged from coming out from the West
I'm still making videos I'm still videos
have to be made they're going up like
when do you let yourself break
if it's in the calendar it has to happen
videos have to happen today I don't care
if I'm lying in bed I don't care I don't
care if I'm in the hospital I've made
videos from the hospital I don't care
where videos have to come up I don't
care if they're the best videos they're
the best
with what I can make right now
if I'm tired they might be lower than my
standard but it's the best of what I can
make right now if I'm in the hospital
it's definitely lower than what I can
make out of the hospital but I'm gonna
make the best of what I can make right
now
be the person who follows through on the
things that you say you're gonna do
because the next time you put something
on your calendar the next time we see
you're gonna get that goal or
do this project you're gonna the next
day wake up and say I'm not I can't do
that I'm not doing that
you're starting to build the identity
either way of the person who follows
through or the person who doesn't follow
through
and every time you say yes to yourself
every time you do it when it's difficult
you start to build up that identity a
little bit more I follow through I
follow through I follow through so then
the next time you put something in your
calendar the next time come up with a
goal you start to believe that it's
actually possible for you to do it
because you're building that identity of
you being the person who actually
follows through
and every time you let yourself off the
hook every time you give yourself a
break every time you say it's okay I'm
not going to do it today every time you
say that
you eat away at that other identity and
start to build a new one
the new identity of the person who
doesn't follow through
you start to believe yourself a little
bit less
the next goal you write down is a little
less credible you don't think you can do
it you're going to realize the next day
that you're not going to follow through
and says it's a very
slippery slope to fall down
so step one is you build a calendar step
two is you become the person who sticks
to your calendar
who follows through on the things that
you say you're going to do that's why
it's important to create a realistic
calendar don't tell me don't tell
yourself you're going to make 100 videos
a day every day
you're going to make a thousand phone
calls a day every day
you're not you're going to write 100
love letters to your wife every day
you're not you're not it's not going to
happen make it a realistic plan for
something you can actually stick to
because again if you just stick to it
guys you will hit your goals
if you stop quitting on yourself if you
stop letting yourself off the hook that
idea you had three years ago should have
already come to Creation because you
just stuck with it just stick with it
step number three so create a calendar
one stick to your calendar number two
three
the environment around you really
matters
videos like this really matters why
create the inspressor to be with you
every morning to give you the Boost to
bring new people like John asraaf and
Oprah and Elon Musk and these people who
lift you up who inspire you hopefully
that's the intention every time
join a group like movement makers be a
part of a community be around other
entrepreneurs who are doing things we're
chasing their dreams we're trying to
make their thing happen when you're when
you create that environment and you
start to shift it
it inspires you to want to play bigger
it inspires you to want to stay
consistent when you are feeling at your
lowest low when you're about to quit on
the thing that you said that you want to
do that's in your calendar you see it
you see it today I'm supposed to do that
like I don't want to do that what brings
you out of it
it's the habits it's the environment
it's the routine
watch another video
join our group like movement makers
get a mentor coach
have an accountability buddy
you have to be around the people who
constantly fill your cup who give you
light who lift you up who make you
believe and help you feel like it's
possible when you do those three things
your life will change
create a calendar
that mapped your actions to your
ambitions
be the person who follows through on
their calendar
and then be around the people videos
resources environment
that encourages you that lifts you up
and makes you feel like it's possible
first of all every time we have a
thought we make a chemical and and if
you have
an unlimited thought you will feel
unlimited and if you have a
self-depreciating thought you'll feel
unworthy and your brain instantaneously
fires circuits that signal another part
of the brain to release peptides or
chemical Messengers that signal hormonal
centers and when we get that arousal
from the thought that we think
those thoughts sometimes weaken the
response weakens the physical body so
turns out that the emotions that are
created from the thoughts are the
signaling mechanisms of the body
thoughts of the language of the brain
and feelings are the language of the
body and how we think and how we feel uh
creates our state of being
so it turns out that the thoughts based
in the stress hormones based in survival
those are the thoughts that begin to
push the genetic buttons that create
disease in other words a person wakes up
in the morning
and the brain is a record of the past
the first thing they do when they wake
up in the morning is they start thinking
about their problems and those problems
are memories that are etched in the
brain that are connected to certain
people certain objects certain things at
certain times and places so if you
believe that your thoughts have
something to do with your destiny the
moment you think about your problems
you're thinking in the past right now
every one of those problems has an
emotion associated with them because
we've experienced them so the moment you
remember your problems now you feel
unhappy now you feel anxious now you
feel fear so the moment we feel those
emotions it takes a thought and a
Feeling
a memory or an image an emotion a
stimulus and a response and we start
conditioning the body emotionally into
the past now the body
is so objective
that it doesn't know the difference
between the real life experience that's
creating that emotion and the emotion
that person's fabricating by thought
alone the body's believing it's in that
environmental condition
so if the environment signals the Gene
and that's the truth and the end product
of an experiences in the environment is
an emotion
we're signaling the same genes and genes
make proteins and if you keep signaling
the same genes you start down regulating
the Gene and make cheaper proteins and
the body begins to break down now that's
an unconscious process
so what goes along with that is the
moment the person feels that emotion of
unhappiness or whatever it is the brain
checks in with the body and says yeah
you're feeling pretty miserable you're
suffering and we tend to generate more
thoughts equal to the feeling that we
have
and so then we get caught in this Loop
of thinking and feeling so if we can't
think greater than how we feel
our feelings have become the means of
thinking then we're thinking in the past
right and so we call that
The Familiar past and then a person gets
going in the day and they start thinking
oh I gotta see this person I got to go
to that meeting I hate doing this and
now they get in their routine and a
habit is a redundant set of automatic
unconscious thoughts behaviors and
emotions that's acquired through
repetition
a habit is when you've done something so
many times that the body now knows how
to do it better than the mind
so now the person running through the
same routine every single day is on
autopilot and their body's now dragging
them
into a predictable future based on what
they did in the past and they've lost
their free will to a set of programs
right so now you have the familiar past
and you have the predictable future
those are knowns
so the only place then reasonably where
the unknown exists is The Sweet Spot of
the generous present moment that is when
the body and mind are free from those
conditions so along with those emotions
that influence the same thoughts people
start becoming more judgmental
they start becoming more impatient they
start becoming more entitled they start
getting more afraid more anxious more
depressed and now the body is literally
being depleted of energy because it's
believing that it's living in an
emergency situation and an emergency you
tap all the body's resources for some
threat whether it's real or imagined and
so then when you're releasing all of
these chemicals we are literally drawing
the body's life force and turning it
into chemistry and so for the short term
that's cool but the arousal that's
created from those stress hormones
is a rush of energy
and so then people use the problems
and the conditions in their life to
reaffirm their conditioning or their
addiction to that emotion and in a sense
they become addicted to the life they
don't even like and this is why change
is so hard
so then when a person makes up their
mind to change and they say okay I'm not
going to say I can't I'm not going to
judge another person I'm not going to
blame I'm not going to complain I'm not
going to make excuses I'm not going to
be a victim I'm not going to talk trash
about anybody I'm just going to stop
well that works out really well for the
first couple hours
and the body's saying you're out of
schedule you normally at eight in the
morning you're getting traffic and
you're angry then at 11 o'clock you
check your emails and you're really
judgmental and frustrated the body's
saying well you've been doing this for
the last 20 years you're just gonna stop
today so now the body which has been
conditioned emotionally to be the Mind
wants to return back to its familiar
territory to the known
so the body starts influencing the mind
and it says you know come on this is a
good time to judge so come on this is a
good time to suffer it's your ex's fault
it's your it's the government's fault
it's uh you know it's the weather what
are the news whatever it is and if we
accept
believe and surrender to that thought
without analyzing it it slips by and it
begins to program the autonomic nervous
system to make those Pharmacy of
chemicals and so that's when the person
makes the same Choice does the same
thing creates the same experience just
for that familiar feeling okay I'll
complain just so I can feel suffering
then they'd rather be unhappy than step
into the unknown to step into
possibility and the hardest part about
that process
first of all is not making the same
choices you did day before and here's
the payoff
you got to stay conscious and not go
unconscious and it turns out that 95 of
the time we're unconscious so if you're
going to stay conscious then there's an
element that also requires a certain
amount of awareness or energy
and you got to step outside of that
unconscious state so the thoughts that
they're thinking are slipping by their
awareness unnoticed because they're
hardwired in their brain because they've
been saying I can't it's too hard my
life will never change at someone else's
fault those thoughts have consequences
in the body
so then if a person then becomes
conscious of those unconscious thoughts
becomes aware of how they speak and how
they act and they notice how they're
feeling and they're no longer the
program they're the Consciousness
outside the program and that's the first
step to change so
they're they're when you when you're
distracted by your environment and you
got your cell phone and your tweeting
and your Instagraming and Facebook and
whatever people do you're distracted by
that feeling
but I now know that if you take a person
and you say Okay close your eyes sit in
the in the Silence of any external
stimulation remove the environment sit
your body down like an animal body is
the animal tell it to stay I'm gonna
feed you you can check your cell phone
you can shower you can have your coffee
but when I say
and so then Here Comes The Challenge
right so and and then if you say then
you're not going to live in The Familiar
future familiar past or predictable
future you're not going to think about
how long you've been meditating what you
got to do you you labor
uh for that present moment
people think when they do this that
they're doing something wrong because
there's such discomfort that comes with
it but they're in the unknown they're
actually doing it right people say I
think I'm meditating wrong I always say
oh no no no you're doing it right
because when you notice that your body
wants to get up and check your cell
phone or have a cup of coffee and you
become aware that it's on autopilot and
wants to do that and you say come on
over here and you return it back to the
present moment
you're executing a will now that's
greater than the program and if the
person wants to just get angry while
they're sitting there there's an arousal
and they notice the body is amping up
and revving up and they settle it back
down now they're telling the body it's
no longer the mind
a third of mine now we've researched
this
and it's tedious in the beginning at
first because David is fighting Goliath
but if you keep practicing it just like
training an animal
sooner or later the body acquiesces
sooner the later the body is trained to
a new mind and when that happens
there's a liberation of energy the body
goes from particle to wave from matter
to energy and there goes that emotion
literally liberated from the body as
energy
so the person who has the strong emotion
to some circumstance in their life
and they're they're working and lowering
the volume to that emotion the more they
lower the volume of that emotion the
more they're going to take their
attention off that person and problem
and they're going to take their power
back there's going to be a break and
their attention from that circumstance
and now they build their own field and
now there's energy to heal now there's
energy to create a new life now there's
energy for the mystical moment because
they've overcome their old personality
self so
I think you know it's not like thinking
positively that's not the message it's
it's overcoming overcoming overcoming
overcoming until we become somebody else
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
the manifestation technique to do every
day check the video right there next to
me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there I think
the Law of Attraction and manifesting
are the same thing so Law of Attraction
for everybody who has not read the
secret is simply your thoughts become
things and it's true we've talked all
about how when you have a negative
self-talk it tends to draw